des charges directes je vous remercie
pour l'invitation m'excuser pour le
temps que j'ai mis à y répondre mais
pour des raisons de gestion de crise
sanitaire
je suis venu plusieurs fois au sénat
évidemment toutes les semaines mais
devant la commission seulement
aujourd'hui je me réjouis d'être devant
vous je j'ai le souvenir de très bons
travaux en commun lorsque j'étais
rapporteur général
l'homologue du sénateur van den berg à
l'assemblée nationale et puis je
découvre cette salle magnifique dans
laquelle vous me faites l'honneur de mme
auditionné et qui sous la protection de
saint louis et coûtait c'est une salle
magnifique je salue également le
l'ensemble des sénatrices et des
sénateurs qui nous suivent en
visioconférence je sais que vous avez
été extrêmement actifs d'ailleurs par
visio conférence soutenant cette crise
que vous avez conduit de nombreuses
auditions utile pour éclairer les débats
de responsables administratifs d'âge ans
d'élu et les travaux que vous avez
menées ces dernières semaines encore une
fois sont importants et croyez-moi nous
les avons suivis j'en avais des résumés
régulièrement de parme et les
collaborateurs de mon cabinet
la crise que nous traversons est bien
sûr inédites vous le savez nous le
savons dans son ampleur comme dans ses
enjeux l épidémie de coronavirus aura
été aura été espérons qu'on puisse dire
aura été une épreuve collective sans
pareil pour toute une génération qui n'a
pas connu la guerre qui n'a pas connu la
famine qui n'a pas connu les grands
fléaux qui ont pu émailler l'histoire de
france je fais quand même partie d'une
génération qui a connu le chômage de
masse réchauffement climatique les
attentats est maintenant une grande
pandémie
j'ai souvent répété ces dernières
semaines nous avons fait nous avons fait
face à une situation totalement inédite
gens parlent ou encore une fois passé
mais c'est une réalité encore prégnante
dans de nombreux territoires l'épidémie
n'étant pas terminée quand je dis que
nous avons fait face je pense évidemment
aux personnels soignants auquel je veux
une fois encore rendre un hommage
sincère
et plein de reconnaissance la première
ligne comme on l'a appelé à résister
avec un courage et un dévouement
exceptionnel je sais que beaucoup
d'entre vous se sont aussi impliqués
pendant cette crise en soutien aux
acteurs locaux au maire et je sais même
que certains parlementaires ont repris
la blouse et le chemin de l'hôpital pour
aider les soignants à faire face dans
des conditions souvent difficiles avec
les contraintes de distanciation
physique le parlement et rester
pleinement mobilisées
parce que la démocratie ne s'arrête
jamais et qu au contraire même dans les
grandes épreuves
on en a beaucoup besoin vous avez été
nombreux à m'alerter sur les situations
spécifiques à vos territoires que ce
soit par courrier que ce soit des cours
des nombreuses séances de questions au
gouvernement ou des textes de loi que
j'ai eu l'honneur de présenter et de
défendre dans votre assemblée
je vous remercie pour vos retours pour
les réactions qui ont souvent permis
d'ajuster les dispositifs je pense là à
la mobilisation des laboratoires
départementaux ou à l'association pleine
et entière des établissements de santé
privés prendre des décisions dans des
circonstances que nous avons connue ce
n'est pas chose simple je me permets
cette litote toute la lumière devra bien
sûr être faite sur la gestion de cette
crise sur la façon dont les pouvoirs
publics se sont mobilisés pour protéger
les français
c'est le sens des travaux parlementaires
ces dernières semaines c'est le sens de
nos échanges aujourd'hui c'est aussi le
sens des commissions d enquête depuis ma
prise de fonctions le 16 février dernier
j'ai toujours voulu la transparence la
transparence à tous les niveaux la
transparence pour tout le monde
il a pu ça peut être un paradoxe m'être
reproché de trop en faire et d'abreuver
par endroit les français de chiffres de
graphiques de statistiques
j'ai totalement franc avec vous je ne
sais pas si j'en ai trop fait en matière
de transparence et d'information une
chose est sûre c'est que je ne me serais
pas pardonné de ne pas en avoir fait
assez
si l'épidémie n'est pas encore derrière
nous nous aurions tort de ne pas
regarder l'avenir en tirant les leçons
qui doivent être tirées
la première de ces leçons concerne notre
système de santé qui ne serait rien sans
toutes celles et tous ceux qui le font
vivre au quotidien
comme vous le savez un exercice inédit
très rapide a commencé le ségur de la
santé
qui doit permettre avec tous les
soignants sur tous les territoires
d'aboutir je le souhaite ardemment à des
accords de la santé depuis trop
longtemps les soignants attendent une
reconnaissance
nous leur devons et nous leur donnerons
depuis trop longtemps des logiques
comptables ont pris le pas sur ce qui
motive ces femmes et ces hommes à se
lever le matin pour aller travailler
c'est-à-dire le soin reconnaître les
soignants et placer le soin au coeur de
notre système de santé voilà ce qui en
ce moment même forme le coeur des débats
du ségur de la santé cela ne se limite
pas aux carrières le ségur doit
permettre d'avancer résolument sur les
investissements dans une logique de
territoire de l'est entre la ville et
l'hôpital
il doit avancer sur la simplification
nous en avons besoin et surtout sur la
proximité le besoin que la ville
l'hôpital et le secteur médico-social
marchent ensemble au service des malades
dans quelques semaines les accords de la
santé viendront non seulement conclure
cet exercice mais aussi et surtout
redonner des perspectives et des moyens
un système de santé dont la crise a
révélé certes les faiblesses mais aussi
des atouts extraordinaires
extraordinaire d'autres sujets d'agenda
sont à venir pour mon ministère des
solidarités et de la santé des sujets
qui nous préoccupent tous je pense en
particulier au sujet de la perte
d'autonomie du grand âge l'assemblée
nationale est en cours d'examen d'un
texte qui porte en lui la création d'une
cinquième branche de la sécurité sociale
l'élargissement d'un périmètre qui
n'avait pas bougé depuis 1945 et qui
fait suite à plus d'une décennie
d'engagements politiques que je je ne
critique pas les raisons et des motifs
mais qui n'avait été jusqu'ici très
difficile de tenir
j'ajoute qu'au cours du ségur de la
santé j'ai souhaité que les
parlementaires puissent avoir toute leur
place et que au des cours de quatre
séances organisées en salle laroque qui
porte le nom d'un des pères fondateurs
de la sécurité sociale les
parlementaires puissent venir exprimer
leur retour leur propre retour
d'expérience suite à cette crise
épidémique
deux séances sont tenues l'ensemble
d'europe des parlementaires sénateurs et
députés
ils sont conviés de tous les groupes
politiques sans exception
il ya près d'une centaine de
parlementaires qui se sont déjà prêtés à
l'exercice j'espère vous voir nombreux
lors des prochaines séances en tout cas
vous y serez toujours les bienvenus
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
suis prêt maintenant à répondre à vos
questions que ce soit sur la crise sur
le ségur la santé étant entendu je le
précise mais vous le savez mieux que moi
monsieur le président vous avez plus
d'habitude les commissions dans quelques
mois que la commission qui débute
prochainement à l'assemblée nationale
puis au sénat portera sur un bilan qui
s'étendra bien au delà de mon propre
ministère je serai donc assez carré dans
des réponses que je vous fournirai
aujourd'hui dans la mesure où ces
commissions d'enquêté sont ouvertes et
que par respect justement pour travail
parlementaire il ya un certain nombre de
réponses que je leur réserve
il ya un certain nombre de questions
auxquelles je ne pourrai montrer
semblablement pas répondre et qui
porterait notamment sur ce qui s'est
passé quand mes prédécesseurs étaient à
ma place ministre des solidarités de la
santé je vous remercie
merci monsieur ministre nous allons de
suite passé donc vos collègues qui
veulent vous poser des questions et je
passe immédiatement la parole à notre
rapporteur pour la branche
assurance-maladie madame catherine de
roche wazemmes d'euros en effet pour moi
nous avons réalisé
beaucoup d'auditions sur cette manche
malasie du cir auquel ont participé
mes collègues alors ma première question
je pense qu'elle va rentrer finalement
dans le champ de ce que vous venez dire
puisque je souhaitais vous interroger
sur sur les stocks d'état des masques
chirurgicaux bon je la pose quand même
vous me direz c'est allé plus commission
enquête depuis 2005 les experts se sont
toujours accordés sur la nécessité d'une
cible d'un milliard de masques
chirurgicaux pour le stock d'état afin
de répondre à une pandémie qui serait
causée par un agent infectieux
respiratoire non contagieuse alors la
cible a été confirmée par le comité
experts de santé publique france en mai
2019 et comment expliquez vous alors les
tergiversations sur cette île malgré les
alertes de sont plus francs sur les
fragilités du stop et que nous soyons
aussi retrouvé qu'un stock d'état que
l'on pourrait qualifier d'appoint et
est-ce qu'on était plutôt sur un choix
fait de constituer un stock tampon en
misant sur la résilience des circuits
internationaux d'approvisionnement de
production nationale elle correspond à
mon avis à aux questions auxquelles elle
n'est pas répondre provisions deuxième
question le concerne les essais
cliniques
alors il une étude du lancet sur les
effets des drogues chloroquine dans le
cas de prise en charge de patients
atteints du coc vite dans cette étude a
suscité un emballement médiatique et
mais elle a été très largement à
discréditer
donc quelle analyse faites-vous de cette
étude
par ailleurs quand est ce que on aura
des des données cliniques propre à la
france sur cette question des
traitements efficaces
bon les selles discovery est plutôt un
échec au regard du nombre de patients
inclus par rapport aux espérances
maintenez-vous
la suspension d inclusion dans les
essais du bras sur l'idh roxy
chloroquine et j'aimerais vous entendre
sur ce que ce qu'a été cette restriction
de la liberté de prescription qui a
beaucoup beaucoup touché les médecins
libéraux je vous avais posé une question
provient avril sur cette thématique en
disant pourquoi les médecins qui le
souhaitent ne soient pas associés à des
essais en libéral mais pas de suite il a
été donné et on vous même également
restreint de la prescription de
d'antibiotiques
et puis autre point c'est la part
important qui a été noté des
renoncements aux soins en effet d'un
développement qui a été certes facilités
de la téléconsultation alors il ya un
décret qui a créé une consultation bilan
et de visu lance un côté à 46 euros pour
la prise en charge des personnes
vulnérables
cela va dans le bon sens mais la mesure
arrive tardivement et le chant est jugée
plutôt restreint par les professionnels
de santé et en outre comme il a eu du
retard qui est des prix elle ne
s'appliquerait que jusqu'au 30 juin
donc dans ces conditions elle est ce que
vous envisagez d'en prolonger
l'application et plus généralement
est-ce que vous avez des éléments de
suivi pour évaluer l'impact du
confinement justement sur les
pathologies connexes autre autre co vide
et le dernier point c'est le ségur de la
santé moi j'irai vendredi à votre
invitation aux réunions ouvrant les
parlementaires lorsque j'ai auditionné
les syndicats infirmiers il s'était
assez remonté si je puis dire pour
employer une expression familière sur le
fait que seul l'ordre des infirmiers
soient soient conviés au ségur
alors qu'en effet les infirmer ont été
en première ligne vous l'avait dit et
également les jeunes médecins s'étaient
émus de ne pas être être conviés mais ça
ça a été rectifié puisque le conseil
d'état ou jeu plus houleux que le oui à
ajuster ou
un ministre acquiesce c'est plus qu'un
jeu c'est qu'il fallait que les soirs
est-ce que depuis le début vous avez
élargir les personnes conviées au cyber
menaces en dévoile à mes questions sur
le ministre merci je vous laisse
répondre à la rapporteure après comme
j'ai seize inscrits on fera cinq par
cinq chinois bien bonjour madame la
sénatrice catherine des roches madame
madame le rapporteur vous l'avez vous
l'avais un peu anticipé sur la première
question qui porte sur le gestion du
stock d'état de de masques je les dis
lorsque je suis arrivé au ministère il y
avait 120 millions de masques
chirurgicaux dans le stock d'état il est
une époque où la france avait compté
beaucoup plus de ces masques j'ai déjà
répondu à plusieurs interpellations
dix ans que de ce que j'avais vu dans
les archives du ministère c'est que le
problème de fond est que un très grand
nombre de masques avait été acheté par
la ministre roselyne bachelot
cela lui avait été le mot reprochés sans
doute très faibles et ces masses qui
n'avaient pas de date de péremption
c'est pour une grosse partie d'entre eux
de ce que je sais et donc année après
année est bien certain nombre de ces
masques sont périmés ou ont été utilisés
et n'ont pas été remplacés il reviendra
à la commission denquête entre autres de
faire la lumière sur les raisons les
motifs
mais au-delà de ça comment est ce qu'on
fait pour l'avenir
quelle stratégie en terme de matériel de
protection je crois que je peux faire
toujours regarder devant que dix ans en
arrière même si je comprends qu'ils
aient des besoins de réponse mais je
crois pas que ce soit une faute
politique encore moins une faute
individuelle je pense que cette épreuve
de gestion collective de pilotage qui
doit nous inviter à revoir complètement
de processus et puis faire des choix
pour la nation même de faire des soit
des choix pour la nation parce que est
ce qu'un milliard et demi ou un milliard
de masques aurait pu suffire dans les
conditions où leur équipe et la
population générale en masques de
protection
oui pendant cinq à six jours donc il
faut qu'on ait une réflexion collective
à laquelle j'inviterai moi toute la
représentation nationale quel que soit
le bord politique encore une fois quelle
que soit la chambre concernée pour qu'on
puisse avoir un travail parce que ça un
coup ça engage
dans la durée je pense que c'est un
débat démocratique qui devra qui devra
se tenir sur les essais cliniques madame
la sénatrice
alors j'ai eu beaucoup d'émotions il ya
encore beaucoup d'émotion parfois une
émotion teintée d'un peu d'agressivité
je ne parle pas là des dés sa chambre
mais d'une partie de l'opinion qui ne
comprend pas et qui est en butte parfois
mobilisés à mauvais escient me
semble-t-il par une partie de la classe
politique mais pas que et je m'étonne de
je m'étonne de cela même madame la
sénatrice vous parlez de l'étude du
lancet
c'est regrettable c'est vraiment comme
une étude une publication une revue
internationale comme le lance est qu'ils
considéraient comme l'une des trois plus
grandes revues internationales de
scientifiques a été obligé de en tout
cas plusieurs des auteurs d'un d'un
papier on demandait le retrait ça ne
veut pas dire pour autant que le papier
ou l'étude aurait montré le résultat
inverse
ça veut juste dire que la qualité
méthodologique était douteuse la qualité
méthodologique a aussi été considérés
douteuses sur s'agissant d'études qui
portait sur l'idh roxy chloroquine mais
sur d'autres médicaments aussi et
plusieurs retraits publications ont eu
lieu citant tech tenté est tenté mais si
bien qu'à la fin ça crée non seulement
un émoi que je peux comprendre qui est
légitime j'ai moi même d'ailleurs écrit
à la revue le lance 27 pour leur
demander de procéder à une relecture par
un comité scientifique indépendant des
données brutes
j'attends leur réponse mais ça ne veut
pas dire madame la sénatrice que le
traitement en question et fait montre de
son efficacité dans des études cliniques
j'ai sollicité le haut conseil de santé
publique ainsi que l' agence nationale
de sécurité du médicament
en réalité j'ai sollicité assez
régulièrement ces deux structures pour
qu'elle produise à vis des
recommandations ce qui m'avait
d'ailleurs permis à la fin du mois de
mars d'autoriser par décret le recours
compassionnel à une prescription sur
décision collective sous la
responsabilité des médecins
prescripteurs en milieu hospitalier pour
des formes graves
la revue de littérature dont je dispose
est d'ailleurs le relevé de conclusions
du haut conseil de santé publique qui
est assez long trait tu pour une toute
petite part de l'article du lancet tu
mets beaucoup plus généralement fait la
revue de toute la publication la
littérature internationale en la matière
et la vie n'a pas évolué du haut conseil
de santé publique
la dernière étude anglaise recovery qui
a été qui n'est pas encore publiée mais
pour lui qui a décidé d'arrêter
d'interrompre le bras hydroxy
chloroquine et je croyais moi je le
regrette
j'avais tout mis en oeuvre pour que si
le traitement fonctionne nous puissions
disposer en quantité en quantité pour
traiter l'ensemble des malades français
j'avais tout mis en oeuvre jusqu'à
m'assurer que nous disposions
suffisamment de matière première sur le
sol français les a autorisées le
laboratoire qui le produit à s'apprêter
en produire davantage les études qui
sont publiés les études à venir dans des
revues très sérieux certains peuvent
être contestées c'est hélas encore une
fois le canton veut aller très très vite
avec la science ce temps scientifique
n'est pas le temps politique
mais les études et les autorités
sanitaires me dise en l'état actuel de
la science qu'on peut inclure un certain
nombre de malades d'ailleurs l'étude
discovery est infondée a ainsi que les
autres études cliniques sont fondés à
utiliser une roxy chloroquine et
l'azithromycine dans leur protocole
thérapeutique
ils peuvent le faire ils ne le font pas
parce que
il n'y a plus beaucoup de nouveaux
malades et qui a plus beaucoup de
nouveaux malades inclure et en fonte et
au fond quand on s'intéresse et j'avais
posé la question à l' agence de sécurité
du médicament depuis la fin du mois de
mars des prescriptions avaient déjà
chuté très fortement de ces médicaments
la plupart des cliniciens faisant le
constat que n'ai pas de données
cliniques probante
al'inverse madame la sénatrice je ne
serai pas plus long sur ce sujet mais si
le haut conseil de santé publique me
disait de ne pas autoriser la
prescription d'un médicament et que je
ne suivais pas la vidéo conseil de santé
publique
je suis à peu près sûr qu'avec un peu de
recul
lorsque l'émotion est retombée et
lorsque les données scientifiques sont
consolidées je suis même totalement sûr
que j'aurais eu droit une commission
denquête elle aurait été justifiée et
j'aurais bien du mal à y répondre sur la
liberté de prescription et la sénatrice
a n'a jamais été entravée l'article 8 du
code de déontologie médicale précise les
choses
le médecin est libre de ses
prescriptions dans les limites fixées
par la loi et compte tenu des données
acquises de la science
compte tenu des données acquises de la
science la liberté de prescription est
ainsi encadrés par la profession
médicale elle même à travers le code de
déontologie
encore une fois notre pays a été
émaillée de drames sanitaires il eu
beaucoup plus de drames sanitaires liés
à l'usagé ou à usage détourné de
médicaments y compris dans une période
très récente que retard de prescription
de certains traitements sur la question
que vous m'avez posé qui traitent
maintenant des personnes âgées à
domicile depuis le déconfinement il ya
une campagne de communication nationale
visant à rappeler les mesures de
protection renforcée pour les personnes
à risque
la création d'une consultation longue
spécifiques proposées par les médecins
traitants pour évaluer les impacts du
confinement sur la santé de ses patients
s'assurer de la continuité des soins
conseiller les personnes en fonction
d'un fragilité et pathologies sur les
mesures de protection a adopté dans le
cadre du déconfinement il ya un bilan
qui est en cours sur l'utilisation de
cette consultation
s'il a lieu de la poursuivre on aime la
sénatrice évidemment que nous la
poursuivrons mais j'attends encore une
fois une évaluation de cela la
consultation
bilan et vigilance a été annoncée le 29
mai ce n'est pas très ce n'est pas très
ancien il n'est pas pour l'instant
prévue celle ci de la prolonger c'est
une mesure temporaire et 7
ça correspond au souhait d'inciter des
patients à retourner chez leur médecin
notamment pour des consultations de
rattrapage pour des maladies qui sont
habituellement prises en charge à 100%
mais nous ferons le bilan de tout cela
et tout ce qui devrait être prolongée le
sera enfin sur la question de
l'organisation du ségur de la santé
savez la première réunion nous étions
trois cents 300 organisations les
parlementaires était d'inviter les
collectivités et les syndicats très
largement était invité l'ensemble
d'ailleurs de ceux qui avaient souhaité
participer je crois ont pu participer
personnes a été privé de slam ensuite
vous avez un comité ségur qui est un
groupe qui quand même composé d'une
cinquantaine de membres qui vise à être
consulté sur les retours des réflexes
des retours d'expérience dans les
territoires sur les consultations
nationales
et puis vous avez ensuite un groupe
spécifique par pilier parce que vous
savez qu'il ya quatre grands piliers
dans le ségur et notamment un groupe qui
est chargé de faire une négociation
sociale sur les revalorisations
salariales qui ne répondent à des règles
les organisations syndicales répondent
des paysages qui sont parfois complexes
ce qui entraîne une sur-représentation
médicale parce que le corps des
soignants hospitalier représenté par les
grandes centrales que sont la cgt la
cfdt force ouvrière
l'unsa et sud alors que les par exemple
les praticiens hospitaliers ont leur
propre syndicat catégoriel ce qui fait
que ça peut donner le sentiment je le
comprends d'une sur-représentation nous
avons diversifié nous avons invité
d'autres structures un syndicat
notamment que vous citez le syndicat
jeunes médecins
nous avons convié voyant qu'il était
déterminée à venir
nous les avons conviés avant le jugement
donc un jugement assez faisait pas a
commenté un jugement mais est donc un
jugement qui nous a incités à inviter
une structure que nous avions invité et
nous en avions d'ailleurs averti le
tribunal donc c'est comme ça
et donc nous avançons et nous avançons
bien et je me permets de répondre une
question vous n'avez pas posée madame la
sénatrice et qui complétera ma réponse
pardon j'ai été long la consultation
nationale à laquelle je m'étais engagé
est destiné à tous les soignants de
l'hôpital a été mise en ligne il ya un
peu plus de 24 heures
elle remporte un franc succès puisque
dans les premières 24 heures nous avons
reçu plus de 13 mille réponses plus de
13000 réponse pour un tiers d'entre
elles elles émanent d'infirmières et
d'infirmiers ce qui veut dire qu'il ya
une vraie appétence pour cette enquête
nationale et je m'en réjouis car elle
viendra aussi enrichir les propositions
et les décisions que nous aurons à
prendre dans les toutes prochaines
semaines
merci monsieur le président monsieur
minispace encore je passe la parole à
monsieur van weynbergh merci monsieur le
président je reviendrai un instant sur
sur les masses mais pas du tout pour
discuter du nombre du simplement pour
poser une question qui est plus
politique
est-ce que devant le manque de masse
qu'on n'a pas bâti une doctrine haddock
sur le peu d'importance de porter un
masque pour se prémunir de cette
épidémie
puisqu'on a entendu cela je pose la
question monsieur le ministre
très respectueusement mais mes questions
elles portent plus sur les aspects
financiers de la gestion sanitaire nous
aurions et nous avons souhaité ici à la
commission des affaires sociales que
nous puissions avoir un plfss
rectificatif
on nous a dit que c'était pas nécessaire
que c'était même difficile de fournir
des chiffres avant le mois de juillet
bon il se trouve que des chiffres nous
en avons puisque on aura l'occasion d'en
discuter avec le transfert de la dette
kdss qu'il faudrait donc attendre
de tendance puisque ce sera le 1er et le
2 juillet ici au sénat est-ce qu'il
faudra attendre le 15 juillet c'est à
dire lors de la discussion de la docte
sur les finances publiques
pour en savoir plus sur l'équilibré de
nos finances sociales
deuxième question ça concerne les aides
à domicile
j'ai entendu ici même le premier
ministre et je crois que celui né ce que
vous l'avez confirmé aussi que les aides
à domicile aurait aussi droit à une
prime pour comme les aide soignante de
l'hôpital comme effectivement les aides
soignantes des ehpad
je crois qu'elles ont concouru à leurs
risques et périls aussi à maintenir un
bon état de santé dans la population
vous l'avez rappelé fragile 1 des
personnes âgées notamment
ou en tous les cas qui sont handicapés
or on dit aujourd'hui que c'est au
département d'assurer le versement de
cette prime or on sait qu'il ya beaucoup
de disparités dans les moyens financiers
de ces départements que des associations
ou les organismes qui ont en charge ces
aides à domicile sont en général en
difficulté financière et depuis fort
longtemps
d'ailleurs des discussions enfin son
entreprise entre les départements et la
cnss qui aurait pas nécessiter d'abonder
d'un fonds spécial la cns a pour qu'ils
puissent verser de façon je dirais qui
table une prime toutes ces aides à
domicile troisième question ça concerne
l'articulation effectivement entre le
plan santé je rejoins ce que la question
posée président tout à l'heure entre le
plan santé 2022
et puis le ségur de la santé il ya
disons une année on a pris un certain
nombre d'orientations que nous estimions
d'ailleurs insuffisante pour l'hôpital
par exemple un milliard sac
sur trois ans nous aurions souhaité est
d'ailleurs seul ministre vous étiez
rapporteur général à l'assemblée on a eu
l'occasion d'en discuter
je pensais que s'il y avait eu un geste
beaucoup plus forts immédiatement pour
l'hôpital on aurait peut-être eu une
attitude à ce moment là mais je ne
critique en rien évidemment l'attitude
qui est aujourd'hui soulignait applaudi
par l'ensemble des français de la part
des soignants mais je crois que on
aurait pu anticiper en quelque sorte je
dirais leur leurs engagements tous les
cas j'ai lu les j'ai écouté surtout
c'est le premier ministre
danse la présentation du ségur les cinq
orientations principales qui
m'apparaissent le d'ailleurs fortes
intéressantes dont la revalorisation des
soignants il ya l'investissement
effectivement dans le domaine de la
santé en particulier pour l'hôpital et
ses modalités de financement de
l'hôpital
beaucoup de questions qui ont déjà été
ici évidemment soulevé maintes et
maintes fois lever les freins aussi à la
réforme du système de santé dieu sait
s'il y en a et je souhaite bon courage
pour en trouver effectivement à
l'aboutissement la gouvernance et puis
effectivement la question numérique qui
vient s'y ajouter aujourd'hui et qui est
très importante évidemment moi j'en
ajouterai une sixième d'orientation 7
financement tout ça
le financement je dis aujourd'hui le
l'assurance maladie mais le système
général sécurité sociale est financé à
plus de 50 pour 53% je crois par des
cotisations sociales
le reste étant assuré par la csg
différentes taxes
multiples et variées la tva aussi
qu'est-ce qu'il n'est pas nécessaire de
penser aujourd'hui à voir autrement
perspective peut-être à moyen terme mais
en tous les cas qui me paraît nécessaire
pour financer tous les besoins ressentis
par logo population j'ai rencontré
récemment je vous invite à elle fait
aussi une organisation un think tank
dirons nous appelons ça comme on veut
av qui a réfléchi à de façon assez
approfondi un système tout à fait
nouveau qui serait de financer sur les
paiements scripturaux à dire paiement
par carte perm en marche est qu un
faible prélèvement 1% à eni pour cent
les vingt-sept 1700 milliards en 2007 et
celle de 2018 ou 2017 de des changes qui
peut y avoir en france hormis évidemment
la spéculation boursière je n'entre pas
dans ce chiffre les vingt-sept mille
milliard
prenez 1% ou 1 an et demi pour cent et
vous avez 300 400 milliards de
disponibles qui permettrait peut-être
d'envisager l'avenir de la sécurité
sociale est d'augmenter aussi les par là
sous strict par la suppression des
cotisations le pouvoir d'achat des
français
voilà c'est une simple suggestion une
sixième orientation qui va me paraît qu
il me paraît nécessaire en tous les cas
de d'envisager merci bien monsieur
daudigny
euh bah voilà le beau mouton
merci monsieur préemption mise de
questions une courte de réflexion la
première question à la lumière de la
crise du coc vide 19
comment voyez-vous à l'avenir le
positionnement de santé publique france
vis-à-vis du ministère de la santé pour
la définition et la mise en oeuvre de la
stratégie de constitution de stocks
nationaux stratégiques de produits de
santé pensez vous qu'après la crise à
shine à la contrainte budgétaire puis la
dilution en 2016 l'eprus au sein de
santé publique france ont contribué à ce
que la question des stocks de masques
perdre progressivement de son importance
stratégique au sommet du ministère santé
publique france nous a en effet indiqué
que de 2016 à 2018
les priorités stratégiques assignés par
un dgs à santé publique france ne
comportait plus aucune mention
spécifique ou stock d'état de masques
deuxième question face à l'enjeu des
pénuries systématique sur certains
médicaments essentiels
le rapport de la mission d'information
sénatoriale sur les pénuries de
médicaments et de vaccins avait
préconisé en 2018
la mise en place d'un pôle public de
production de médicaments essentiels
dans notre arsenal thérapeutique
assis sur une collaboration entre des
structures publiques comme l'agent
générale des équipements et produits de
santé et la pharmacie centrale des
armées et privés dont les entreprises
pharmaceutiques
plusieurs initiatives remettent au goût
du jour cette initiative
à la lumière des tensions observées
pendant l'épidémie de covile 19
quelle est votre position monsieur le
ministre sur cette question
comment comptez vous répondre à la
problématique récurrente des tensions
d'approvisionnement de médicaments à
l'avenir notamment au niveau européen
puis une courte réflexion sur un sujet
des veaux déjà évoqué celui de la prime
exceptionnelle alors qui est versée ou
qui n'est pas versée
dans le secteur sanitaire le secteur
social et le secteur médico-social
monsieur le ministre les remontées sont
innombrables alors je pourrais citer
celle du département des je pourrais
citer dans le département de la loire
celle reçue par mon collègue jean claude
tissot et ses remontées traduisent
beaucoup d'après d'incompréhension et de
mécontentement avec les questions posées
pour l'attribution d'un prime pour les
personnels etc
externaliser des ehpad pour les
personnels des établissements privés à
but lucratif pour les salaires des
services d'aidé à domicile par exemple
je vous ne vous faire pas monsieur le
ministre de ce sujet qui sera sans doute
d'ailleurs évoqué je les imagine par
d'autres collègues dans la suite de
cette séance je vous remercie
merci bien je passe la parole à monsieur
chassaing d'achat ça n'est pas de
prendre n'y a pas de problème de son
monsieur chasse à une fois monsieur le
président vous m'entendez oui est ce que
vous entendez oui mais nous oui merci
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre que donc très rapidement donc
en fait au début vous n'aviez pas de
test et pas de masque et bien sûr il
vous restait plus que pour le
confinement si vous voulez alors bien
sûr cette épidémie n'était pas du tout
prévisible et elle était complètement
inédite
je pense que bon vous avez fait le
maximum à partir du moment où bien sûr
et vous manquez de deux tests et 2 et
deux masques et je voudrais aussi bien
sûr remercié le personnel mais aussi
l'armée les tac et qui ont pu avec le
personnel soignant finalement à ce que
les personnes les malades qui avaient
besoin donc de réanimation mais tout le
monde a pu en avoir
donc je voulais vous en quelques
questions
donc pourquoi ce manque de tests par
rapport à l'allemagne
c'est vrai qu' il fallait bien sûr ce
que vous faites maintenant c'est à dire
tester trouver contact isolé et et c'est
vrai que ça aurait été important de
pouvoir le faire au départ les masques
les questions déjà été posée donc j'y
reviens pas pourquoi on n'a pas fait au
niveau des médicaments pourquoi on n'a
pas fait de l'expérimentation sur
l'hydroxyde chloroquine vitraux max au
début puisque c'était apparemment
c'était le traitement doit être fait au
début des symptômes aussi
troisième question pourquoi on a pas
impliquer davantage les médecins
traitants dans la première phase
maintenant bien sûr ils sont impliqués
après le après l'essai eux qui vont
envoie les malades aux tests et après
ils sont également informés détester et
pour s'impliquer aussi bon
les contacts mais peut-être qu'au début
on aurait pu je pense davantage d
impliquer en ce qui concerne les 400
euros de prime donc bon vous avez
répondu favorablement pour les hôpitaux
de la corrèze pour ce qui pour les
personnes qui sont impliquées au cockpit
je pense que il faut être quand même
assez large parce que il ya beaucoup de
personnels qui sont impliqués dans koh
vite dans l'est dans les hôpitaux
enfin bien sûr vous l'avez vous l'avez
dit il faut bien sûr modifié pour suivre
le ségur de la santé pour ce qui est le
domicile je reviens pas tout cela était
tout ce qui avait été mis en place
bien sûr à l'hôpital réformer le
financement le personnel ça vous en
avait parlé moins de temps aussi passé
dans les démarches administratives et je
voulais aussi indiqué qu' il serait
souhaitable de mettre en place des pôles
d'activités de soins immédiats à
domicile même si et ça c'était mon
amendement même si eux il n'y a pas de
d'établissement santé dans la cpt est ce
que les il faut absolument que dans le
cadre d'une cpps avec les maisons de
santé on puisse avoir un endroit où les
gens peuvent aller ou pour les soins non
programmés et enfin certains j'ai acheté
sont trop importants ne pensez vous pas
que il faudrait faire un ingé acheter
départemental et enfin la perte
d'autonomie sera bien sûr comme vous
l'avez dit une priorité parce que les
personnes les pensionnaires en ehpad
sont très importants il faudra bien sûr
là aussi augmenté beaucoup le nombre de
personnels merci je sais pas
la parole à brigitte micouleau merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
ma première question s'adresse donc et
sur le secteur de la santé ce sont une
soixantaine de soignants région
occitanie ils se sont portés volontaires
pour apporter leur aide aux
établissements de l'ap-hp en
ile-de-france tellement touchée par
l'épidémie du coït 19
c'est les infirmiers anesthésistes de
toulouse de la haute garonne et de la
région quitte à nier de l'ensemble du
territoire d'ailleurs tout comme de
nombreux professionnels paramédicaux
sont extrêmement déçus des orientations
données dans la mise en place de la
grande consultation peuvent constitue le
ségur de la santé avec une absence
totale de représentativité de leur
profession ils ont été sur tous les
fronts durant le pic de la pandémie sont
porteurs de propositions constructives
monsieur le ministre comment
envisagez-vous le mieux au mieux de les
intégrer et d'intégrer les intégrer aux
réflexions au cours du ségur de la santé
ma deuxième question porte sur
l'expérience du chu de toulouse et du ps
ceux reçus le suivi des patients
victimes du couronne à virus sans avoir
forcément été hospitalisés en
réanimation beaucoup peinent à s'en
remettre
la lenteur du rétablissement à des
complications pulmonaires toux et
extrême fatigue est une particularité du
covic 19 le degré d'atteinte pulmonaire
est un élément fondamental à connaître
pour la prise en compte du traitement a
préconisé aux malades a peint une
expérience très intéressante est menée
entre le siège toulouse et le cnes ils
se sont alliés pour développer un projet
d'intelligence artificielle avec un
objectif
l'interprétation des échographies
pulmonaire pour évaluer le niveau de
gravité du virus et prédire son
évolution
ne serait-il pas intéressant de diffuser
plus largement cette expérience
prometteuse dans l'identification des
formes sévères vous remercie merci bien
qu'enfin donc pour cette première série
madame meunier monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je fais partie de
celles et ceux qui vous ont écrit
pendant les semaines de confinement et
comme la réponse n'est pas encore arrivé
j'en profite je vais vous parler de
situation très particulière de ces
femmes et de ces familles en parcours de
procréation médicalement assistée et qui
avant le 12 mars dernier était dans un
protocole donc tout s'est arrêté
ça a été synonyme d'inquiétude de ce
stress cette interruption de traitement
et les interrogations étaient nombreuses
donc c'était l'objet de mon courrier
pour ces femmes qui ont débuté à un
parcours à l'étranger
une course contre la montre a été engagé
dès la proche du déconfinement et là
encore plus avec la probable réouverture
des déplacements dans l'union européenne
les délais vous le savez sont dont cinq
semaines cinq semaines entre avant
l'arrivée en clinique pour provoquer une
simulation une stimulation ovarienne
donc cela demande de la préparation et
de l'anticipation
donc ces femmes elles ont été et ces
familles ont été laissés dans le doute
dans le flou sans réponse donc ce qui
est quand même
ethiquement difficilement acceptable
donc je souhaite se savoir monsieur le
ministre
quelles vont être les dispositions en
vigueur
quelles sont ses dispositions pour
permettre la reprise des protocoles dame
paix en france et à l'étranger et en
particulier est ce que vous envisagez en
lien avec la caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie de déroger à l'âge
limite des 43 ans pour la prise en
charge de cet acte pour les femmes qui
par malheur et par bonheur on vu pendant
ces semaines dépasser le cap et fêter
leur anniversaire donc voila c'était
u7 question que je vous avais envoyé par
écrit que jan postman merci monsieur le
ministre c'est à vous beaucoup de
questions à son président mais beaucoup
de questions très intéressantes je vais
essayer d'y répondre au mieux sans être
trop long pour le sénateur jean marie
vanlerenberghe monsieur le rapporteur
général
il ya une doctrine pour le port du
masque était protégé les soignants cette
doctrine là elle n'a jamais été discuté
dans la mesure où elle est connue elle
est écrite elle est validée elle a été
priorisé dans des conditions très
difficiles avec un socle d'état qu'il
était qu'il fallait gérer j'allais dire
en bon père de famille pour éviter qu'on
se retrouve avec absence complète de
masques
il fallait protéger l'airé à protéger
les urgences et puis distribués en ville
des millions de dizaines de millions de
masques ont maintenant des centaines de
millions de masques pour voir aussi
protéger un maximum les soignants
c'était des sacrifices importants je
pense aux dentistes par exemple qui ont
consenti à arrêter leur activité faute
de masques ffp2 pour pouvoir se protéger
systématiquement sur ligier solliciter
les agences et autorités de santé le
haut conseil de santé publique les
sociétés d'hygiène hospitalière de
maladies infectieuses pour savoir
quelles étaient les conduites à tenir si
vous m'interrogez sur la doctrine du
port de masques en population générale
sur la porte en général cette doctrine
de tête dont je disposais quand la crise
épidémique a commencé et fondée sur des
recommandations bien antérieure à mon
ministère notamment du haut conseil de
santé publique sur la base d'études elle
était qu'il n'y avait pas de preuves du
port du masque que le port du masque en
population générale soit de nature à
protéger dans une épidémie comme celle
là à l'exception et je l' ai d'ailleurs
dit à plusieurs reprises de la situation
où au moins 60 % de la population serait
amené à le porter dans des bonnes
conditions et en permanence sur le
sénateur le port du masque est
recommandée depuis plusieurs semaines et
même obligatoire par endroits je ne sais
si dans vos territoires ou pourtour du
sénat vous avez eu l'occasion de vous
balader dehors j'ai envie de vous
demander si avec le recul sur l'épidémie
vous considérer qu'aujourd'hui il ya 60%
la population qui pourtant avec temps
capacité maintenant se fournir qui porte
le masque en permanence je ne le crois
pas mais encore une fois il faut la
science évolue les recommandations
évolue peu près parce que vous savez
monsieur le sénateur que l'organisation
mondiale de la santé recommande
désormais ce dans certaines situations
le port du masque en population générale
vous savez depuis quand depuis le 5 juin
ce que je veux dire c'est que qui est
des questions qu'on s'interroge on se
demande qu'on cherche à comprendre je
l'entends parfaitement et même les
questionnements un peu plus vif qui
consiste à dire est-ce que vous avez
menti pour cacher la misère est à
j'entends ces questions mais vous avez
quand même un certain nombre d'éléments
factuels sous les yeux avec des
recommandations nationales et
internationales date et sur lesquels
j'ai eu l'occasion de communiquer un
certain nombre de fois semaine après
semaine
ça ne veut pas dire que la réponse
satisfera ceux qui considèrent que le il
aurait dû disposer de masques dans
toutes les situations dans toutes les
conditions dès le début de l'épidémie et
je le regrette je suis le premier à
regretter mais en aucun cas je n'ai
cherché à masquer je suis arrivée 17
février
l'épidémie avait commencé oui c'est moi
ou sans mauvais jeu de mots l'épidémie
l'épidémie je suis arrivé le 17 février
le nombre de masques dont je disposais
dans le souk d'état je les dis
rapidement et je ne suis pas tributaire
mais encore une fois je ne jetterai la
pierre sur aucun des prédécesseurs y
compris d'ailleurs des opposants
politiques
si je considérais qu'il y avait une
responsabilité individuelle
je serai amené à le dire et je l'aurais
déjà dit sur le plfss rectificatif
autre sujet de salles deux ambiances on
n'a pas eu de consolidation des déficits
dans le champ des affaires sociales
rendant impossible l'exercice un plfss
rectificatif sincère nous sommes
aujourd'hui à 52 milliards de déficit de
la sécu nous aura pas échappé que dans
le pgl paisiello nous prévoyons
transférés à la cades est ce une somme
qui correspond à une dette qui est plus
importante que la dette que nous
constatons actuellement
signe que nous anticipons un creusement
de sa dette parce que d'une part une
course il reste encore une partie de la
population qui bénéficie de mesures de
chômage partiel et d'autre part parce
qu'ils aient encore des dépenses de
santé qui sont engagés nous continuons
d'acheter du matériel et donc les choses
n'étant pas consolider l'exercice avait
moins de sens
il aurait fallu sinon faire un pôle scs
rectificatif hebdomadaire est ce qui
nous aurait tous mobilisés beaucoup de
temps et il n'aurait pas eu forcément
l'enjeu de la sincérité mais je
comprends votre question et je suis très
attaché comme vous
l exercice budgétaire annuel sur la
question des aides à domicile évidemment
que les aides à domicile elles sont
fondamentalement qui celle de santé mon
premier déplacement ministériel
la première semaine où j'ai été nommé
hormis les déplacements qu'aux vide a
été pour rendre hommage aux aides à
domicile et faire une annonce qui
aujourd'hui paraît très dépassée mais
qui était une annonce de rallonge
budgétaire parce que je considère que
les aides à domicile sont des
travailleurs pauvres
ça fait partie des personnes qui sont
indispensables au fonctionnement de la
société qu'on ne voit pas sauf quand on
en a besoin mais sans lesquelles on ne
pourrait pas verser dans la société
il a une notion à laquelle je crois
beaucoup qui était ringard disais je
crois que d'ailleurs c'était pas c'était
pas forcément quelqu'un que j'avais
soutenu politiquement mais c'était
martine aubry qui avait fait campagne
sur la notion du caire de prendre soin
c'est un très joli mot le prendre soin
on se rend compte de notre vulnérabilité
à différents moments de notre vie quand
on est tout petit on s'en rend pas
compte mais l'ambiance et on est de fait
vulnérables quand on est très âgées en
perte d'autonomie et quand on est malade
et là dans une épidémie nous avons une
prise de conscience collective du fait
que nous sommes vulnérables
c'est le bon moment pour reconnaître la
place de ces femmes
il ya aussi des hommes et de ces femmes
dans la société et de les revaloriser et
de les conforter jeudi de ces femmes en
appuyant parce que historiquement on les
théories du caire c'est intéressant de
regarder et écrit des genders féminine
je pense à johan trop tôt à carol
gilligan qui avait postulé que puisque
les armes ont donné ltd le consacre qu'à
un moment donné quand les femmes avaient
aspire à travailler
on leur avait dit bah vu vous avez une
variété particulière qui fait que vous
occuper des enfants vous allez vous
occuper des personnes fragiles est
malade et comme c'était des métiers
historiquement féminisé il était sous
payés et 40 50 60 ans plus tard ces
métiers sont restés sous payés je crois
que la responsabilité collective que
nous avons vis-à-vis de ces personnes
est énorme et que donc il faut pouvoir
bouger sur la question particulière de
la prime c'est un mécanisme budgétaire
croyez moi qui nous a empêchés
d'attribuer par l'état une prime aux
aides à domicile puisque dès lors qu'une
partie d'un salaire était versée par
l'assurance maladie
tout soignants il a reçu une prime les
terres de domicile ne sont pas du tout
rémunéré par la ddt par l'assurance
maladie et nous travaillons avec les
départements
régulièrement et notamment avec
dominique bussereau que je salue et qui
est extrêmement investi sur ce sur ce
champ pour faire en sorte que les
départements de puces à attribuer une
prime à ses aides à domicile mais de
toute façon avec ou sans prime
moi je veut revaloriser les aides à
domicile et les revaloriser sensiblement
on va en parler dans le ségur on va en
parler dans le plan grand âge autonomie
vous dire également que
financement par prélèvement scripturaux
scripturaux ça me semble s'apparenter
malgré tout une taxe faire une espèce de
tva bis mais mais pourquoi pas enfin
vous avez jamais arrivé de reprocher aux
parlementaires de ne jamais proposé deux
pistes de pour financer des dépenses qui
propose moi je d'accord pour tout
regarder avec vous sept sénateurs
je ne suis pas et vous dire la matière
pour le sénateur d'audignies quel sera
l'avenir du stock stratégique et qui
devra le piloter qui devra organiser
réflexion collective va avoir monsieur
le sénateur ils vous diront les tirerons
les conclusions de la période
regardons comment aménager les agences
sanitaires est ce qu ils nous refont
l'eprus est-ce que ce que le santé
publique rend ce qui fait un travail
formidable en matière de politique de
prévention et de l'information publique
est suffisamment outillée outillés en
matière de logistique
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas si une
structure aurait pu être suffisamment
outillée pour faire face à l'épidémie
aussi brutal et intense que celle que
nous avons connue
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas pour
répondre à ce stade mais je me pose les
mêmes questions que vous et j'aurai
beaucoup de plaisir à travailler avec
vous et avec d'autres sur la refonte si
elle était nécessaire de notre système
de sécurité sanitaire sur le pôle public
des médicaments et sur la stratégie
européenne
oui nous ne pouvons pas rester en totale
dépendance du point de vue de la chine
ou de l'inde pour des médicaments plus
de 90% des matières premières qui
servent à fabriquer des médicaments
essentiels se trouve au bout du monde et
aujourd'hui encore on manque de propofol
pour les services de réanimation pour
les blocs opératoires
on aurait la compétence pour fabriquer
du propofol mais nous n'avons pas les
matières premières dont il suffit même
pas de réimplanter des usines de
production y avait un rapport qui avait
été confié par un prédécesseur à
monsieur bio qui proposait de
réindustrialiser la france et je pense
l'europe en européen convaincu ça fait
beaucoup plus sens d'autant que c'est
beaucoup de l'usiné seveso chimiques
implantées que je pense que c'est bien
si on répartit un peu les contraintes
mais qu'on ait une politique européenne
en matière de médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur oui mais il faudra
aussi penser la politique européenne en
matière de fourniture en matière en
matière première pour fabriquer ces
médicaments sur la prime exceptionnelle
du sénateur elle est aussi attribué aux
établissements de santé privés non
lucratifs et privé lucratif j'ai écrit
ou fédération il ya quelques jours pour
les rassurer sur ce point c'est tout à
fait normal
j'ai été le premier à m'offusquer
lorsque je crois que c'était au sénat on
me faisait reproche de ne pas avoir
mobilisé les établissements de santé
privés j'entends avec satisfaction
aujourd'hui que tout le monde reconnaît
qu'ils ont été mobilisés et c'est tant
mieux parce que ça traduit davantage la
vérité et donc il est normal que un coup
de pouce puisse être donnée pour saluer
aussi les soignants sur le monsieur le
sénateur
chassin
sur la question des tests monsieur le
sénateur les tests on en avait pas au
début de l'épidémie parce qu'il
n'existait pas de test le test pcr pour
dépister le kobe de 19 il a été mis au
point notamment en allemagne
lorsque le virus a été identifié
n'existait pas avant
et nous n'avons pas non plus de test et
vous le savez je vous taquine pas du
tout en disant le même vous méprenez pas
mais on n'a pas non plus de tests
existants en préparation pour des virus
qu'on n'a pas encore découvert donc une
fois que le virus est arrivé il a fallu
implanté créer d implanter des
structures de pcr lourde
on a acheté 18 machines à destination du
secteur public ainsi que des machines à
destination du secteur privé des
laboratoires biologique se sont équipés
pour pouvoir monter en charge en termes
de tests mais la politique de tests
n'étaient pas non plus forcément
corrélée à la capacité à réaliser ces
tests au sein d'un tout le monde était
testé contamines montjoie
cinq patients des dizaines de tests
faits c'est à 2 les gens étaient testés
aussi systématiquement quand on voulait
casser des chaînes de contamination au
stade épidémique les recommandations à
nouveau pardon mais les recommandations
de l'organisation mondiale de la santé
était on ne teste on le dépiste que les
eaux ne confirme biologiquement que les
diagnostics que chez les gens qui sont
très malades très fragiles ou les
soignants les autres on les considère
cliniquement comme malade et le
traitement il aime donc quintet soit
positif ou non le traitement elle-même
isolement elle même la prise en charge
est la même aujourd'hui nous sommes
arrivés à un stade qui beaucoup de
proches du stade 2 le stade où on
dépiste tout le monde systématiquement
et j'en veux pour preuve que 99% des
prélèvements que nous faisons sont
négatifs explique 1% test positif si que
l'émail se sont resserrés et c'est
important pour également le
l'expérimentation de la bithérapie ah
oui l'identique le rock in vitro
missiles au début alors je ne sais pas
monsieur le sénateur qu'elle est là qui
est le bon timing pour arriver à
démontrer par une étude clinique
validées scientifiquement qu'il ce
traitement fonctionne ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que les études qu'ils
ont publiées montrent que j'ai des
formes graves
des études sont négatives l'immense
majorité des études sont négatives
que chez un modèle animal à qui on
inocule le la maladie certains étant
protégé par hydroxy chloroquine et
l'azithromycine ils font la même maladie
avec les mêmes complications que les
observations qui ont été faites en
population de personnes qui sont malades
avec des panneaux logique trop chronique
qui justifient qu'il soit traité par
chloroquine au long cours ils ont autant
développer la main dit que les autres en
tout cas sur les études publiées dont je
dispose donc les études publiées tout
court et que et qu'en fait en définitif
jeu je le regrette encore une fois je
suis le premier à le regretter
je suis la santé si j'avais eu un
traitement qu'il avait été en plus
français de production française à
capacité à fournir à toute la population
il ya des études qui ont été initiées en
france en phase précoce je pense à
arranger je passe je pense à montpellier
des études qui ont été faites en
bithérapie hydroxy chloroquine
azithromycine il n'y a pas de
publication parce que les cohortes de
malades inclus sont trop faibles
circa passé de malades pour avoir un
résultat statistique ça ne voudrait rien
dire parce que le nombre de malades à
inclure était devenu insuffisant par
contre j'ai eu aussi monsieur le
sénateur des alertes des agences de
santé je ne suis pas là gens se sentent
et j'ai des alertes de l' agence de
santé de sécurité du médicament sur des
effets indésirables liés à l'habitation
[Musique]
on